there's a name that you should become
more familiar with as we move on in this
Republican majority in the House of
Representatives and that is James Comer
Republican of Kentucky he is the chair
of the house oversight and
accountability committee
an important spot an important
uh committee assignment especially for a
chairman
he has colleagues who will join him
valiantly in their fight to provide
oversight
in the Congress Paul gosar a vowed white
nationalist Lauren bobert
High School Dropout multi-time fail
failure at the GRE or excuse me the GED
thinking of grad school stuff and
Marjorie Taylor green prolific
conspiracy theorist
Q Anon adherent they're also there with
him and James Comer the reason I'm
saying you're going to know his name
more is because he's going to be making
the rounds the Press is going to be
asking him questions about what his
agenda is what do you plan to do
as chairman of the house oversight and
accountability committee
and uh you I hope will not be surprised
to know that he even categorizes himself
as just an average guy with average
ability at best he says watch this and
then we'll play some other Clips keeping
this particular clip in mind as we move
forward
and I'm just an average guy
with average ability at best that's Fed
Up
with the process in Washington DC I'm
fed up with the public corruption I'm
fed up with the excessive spending and I
want to do something about it and that's
that's my
goal now look this could be true he
could be an average guy with average
average abilities at best and some
people might be happy with that some
people may think oh we need more of a
Citizens representative uh segment of
our country it should be a citizen
government and I believe that to be true
but there's a certain skill set an
intellect level that you should
um just by virtue of qualification not
by some constitutional standard of
whether or not you're able to run for
office but you should be Adept at
certain things you shouldn't be just an
average guy with average ability at best
especially when you're the chairman of
the house oversight and accountability
committee wrangling the likes of Lauren
bobert and Marjorie Taylor green and
Paul gosar
part of their their their their their
efforts in that committee will be
investigating obviously by the name of
the committee government oversight
and he vows not to be uh investigating
Donald Trump but and the reason he gives
flies in the face of the reason that
he's actually going to be investigating
Joe Biden it all doesn't make any sense
I don't expect anybody to expect it to
make sense coming from James Comer
Republican of Kentucky watch this
with respect to Trump you know a lot of
the media I went on I love Pam Brown and
our our friends she's from Kentucky went
on CNN last night her last night on that
show uh she says well you know you why
aren't you investigating Trump's
mishandling of documents there's a
special counsel
there's a special counsel and I'm
confident that special counsel is
looking at everything Trump has been
investigated for six years we're
fighting documents although it sounded
like you are planning on asking the
national so you are asking questions
about Trump's documents what was in them
how they got there I I would I'm going
to try to explain this as best I can
we're investigating the Biden family for
influence peddling
we learn that they have
classified documents in multiple
locations
we are concerned is that part of the
influence pedal I don't know
just an average guy with average ability
at best you can't even keep his nonsense
straight he's not you heard him not
investigating Donald Trump because
there's been assigned a special counsel
but he is investigating Biden
for the thing he's not investing
investigating Trump for even though
there's also been a special counsel
appointed in the Biden case
and then he's like oh let me pause here
and try to gather my thoughts uh let me
uh try to explain this as best I can now
that I got myself in this pickle I'm
just an average guy with average ability
in intellect at best
Emily I believe that was what her name
was questioning him there
and then when she presses him a little
bit further about other things that
maybe he should be investigating like
what took place in Memphis with Tyree
Nichols
he just says well it has really crossed
my mind I haven't even thought about
that because Joe Biden it's a five alarm
fire
because Joe Biden is volunteered that
they found classified information he
wasn't hoarding it he didn't abscond
with it as soon as they found out they
they spilled the beans on themselves but
that needs investigated not rampant
systemic police abuse of American
citizens unarmed American citizens watch
this stupid stupid moment I encourage
Jim to work with me on on the stuff that
we're looking into and oversight I stay
out of his business in judiciary okay so
you don't think it's necessarily
something I should be looking into I
haven't even thought about it to be
honest with you I mean I I was asked
about it it's a terrible thing certainly
there are bad apples in in every
profession bad politicians bad police
officers and they need to be held
accountable so I'm confident those
police officers are going to be held
accountable he's confident they're going
to be held accountable but not by him
not by congress not by the chairman of a
very powerful committee with with
so much in its purview
there's bad apples everywhere
look I'm just an average guy with with
sub average abilities y'all why would I
look at that
bad apples what horrible luck for Tyree
Nichols that every single armed agent of
the state that responded to to to uh
address him under the authority and the
color of law what bad luck that every
single one of those cops happened to be
one of the bad apples
or is it more likely that the the
epidemic of Bad Apple dumb in policing
in America is far more advanced than
many people would like to believe
and this is a member of Congress who
could do something about it but instead
he's just an average guy
with an average skill set